protests on the streets near minneapolis
and anger once again
named at the police force prompted by
the death of yet another black man
this time 20 year old dante wright
police in brooklyn center a suburb of
minneapolis say officers pulled over a
man just before
2 pm on sunday and discovered he had an
outstanding arrest warrant
as they tried to detain him he got back
in the car
one officer shot dante wright who then
drove away but hit another vehicle
he was declared dead at the scene one
officer had fired
a weapon striking the driver
the vehicle continued and eventually
crashed and
medical resources were then deployed to
the scene to aid the people in both the
vehicle that was crashed into
and the original group
the driver of the vehicle was was
deceased
his mother was on the phone with him
when it all happened she said they
pulled him over for having air
fresheners hanging from the rear view
mirror
an illegal offense in minnesota i heard
scuffling
and i heard the police officers say
dante don't run and then
the other officer said put the phone
down and hung it up
and then two like a minute later i
called and his girlfriend answered which
was the passenger in the car
and said that he'd been shot and she put
it on the
driver's side and my son was laying
there lifeless
people are on edge here as all this
happened just 16 kilometers away from
where george floyd was killed in may
last year
former police officer derek shoven is
currently on trial after he was filmed
kneeling on lloyd's neck for more than
nine minutes during the arrest
the video sparked global protests
against police brutality and racism in
the united states
too many drugs chauvin is charged with
murder and manslaughter his trial is in
its third week in a courthouse
surrounded with tight security
the minnesota national guard troops
deployed for the trial have now been
sent to brooklyn center
there are local reports of some
protesters destroying and looting local
businesses
anti-police protesters had already been
rallying since the trial started
who knows if there's going to be a
difference in this world who knows if
it's going to be the last time that we
all come together in something like this
so we're just peacefully protesting um
we're not gonna keep
taking police killing black people for
no reason traffic stops
you know mental health problems so this
is just the way that we've learned to
stand in solidarity and show that we're
not gonna you know we're standing for a
cause
the governor of minnesota says the state
is mourning another life
of a black man taken away by law
enforcement
al jazeera let's now speak to our
correspondent john hendren who is in
minneapolis for us
john we've already seen just how tense
this community is and that's really not
going away
that's right it's a hauntingly familiar
scene here and the protesters didn't
have far to go because they were already
here in town waiting for the beginning
of week three of the derrick chauvin
murder trial in the case
of chauvin allegedly killing george
floyd
so police ended up having to deploy
tear gas after hundreds of demonstrators
came up on a police station in a tactic
that has become
familiar since last summer here in
minneapolis
they were in brooklyn park that's about
uh 16 kilometers away
and it is within the sphere of the riots
and looting
that happened after the may 25th killing
of george floyd
and last night that looting extended
overnight
here into minneapolis we're told that in
brooklyn park itself there were about 20
buildings
that were targeted and so you had
national guard troops from here in
minneapolis
sent out there and we're also told there
will be more uh national guard troops
coming into the city so this incident
could not
really have happened at a worse time
but of course the protesters are here
preparing for the chauvin case
uh what happens after this incident we
will see in the coming days
and john as you mentioned there it is
day 11 of the chauvin trial today people
will
clearly be watching more closely than
ever
that's right we are expecting the
prosecution to wrap its case either
today or tomorrow we're expecting
a doctor uh possibly a another
pulmonologist that is a lung
expert and then we are expecting what
they call a spark of life
testimony that's something they do here
in minnesota where
a member of the family talks about the
impact
on the family and who the person was
who died that's the kind of thing we
normally hear in the closing
arguments of a trial and i'm sure we'll
hear them there as well the witness
impact statements that come often before
sentencing here they're going to do it
today that will be the emotional
close we expect of the prosecution's
case and then the defense is going to
have to come out
and they've got a lot of work to do
because expert after expert has
testified that george floyd died of
asphyxiation
that he died with derek chovin's knee on
his neck and police officers including
the chief of police here who
fired derek chauvin after that event
said that those techniques
were not approved so we're expecting
some exciting testimony in the coming
days
we're told that the close is likely on
the defense side to take
two three days or so instead of the two
weeks
or so that we've seen with the
prosecution that is typical it's not a
matter of who has more witnesses it's a
matter of what the witnesses have to say
john hendren following all of that for
us there in minneapolis we'll be
speaking to him later as well thanks so
much john